how to make a viral video so I got a
great question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys Jonathan who wrote
in the say I watched your videos every
morning I was able to build an online
Academy and start growing hope you share
how to create a viral marketing video
for start-up businesses keep inspiring
thanks a lot so before I get into my
advice I want to preface it with it's
really hard to make a viral video and a
lot of times when you plan it it doesn't
work out I remember being at a
conference where the topic was viral
videos and they had four experts on
stage talking about it and none of them
had actually created a viral video they
analyzed cases that did go while that
did take off but they had never actually
done it themselves and some of the ones
that they have put up my videos had
already done better than what they were
showing off so it's really hard okay
you're not going to get a viral video by
doing the market research and crunching
the data and seeing if we combine these
five elements together then we'll get a
viral video it doesn't work out that way
because people aren't falling in love
with data the number one thing you have
to have your video is you need to stand
for something the video has to be
important has to make me feel something
has to get me excited right if you don't
do that it's not going to work right it
just combine elements together it's not
going to take off so you have to have a
purpose what's the purpose of this video
the best video that I've done has over
half a million views it's not like multi
million but it's not 500 views it's over
half a million views and the video is
called believe I'm a tourism and believe
is the theme right we created this video
hoping that it would do well but with a
noble purpose right we are standing for
something we want people to be inspired
we want people to watch it every day and
feel like they want to go and make a
positive change in their lives that's
why we created it so your your intention
has to be noble it has to stand for
something going in not just hey I want
to make a video to promote my business
that's not going to go viral because
people don't care right if I said hey
here's a video about Evan
going to go viral okay but if you create
a video that touches people somehow that
stands for something important then it's
much more likely to take off because
people love it and they believe in it
number two work with the best if you
want to have success with your video
find people who who can articulate your
creation what's in your head and turn it
into video I have done it before and who
are really great artists of what they do
if you're trying to do it yourself or if
you have somebody on your team who kind
of knows how to do video editing the
chances of that taking off are really
tiny when i created my belief video is
called believe by materials n because i
partnered up with a youtube artist named
a tourism and this is what he does he
creates amazing inspirational
motivational videos and i went to him
because I was already watching his stuff
I was watching his content I love them I
couldn't wait for the next one to come
out they engaged me and I thought you
know what if anybody's going to do a
great job of making this video it's
going to be him if anybody can take that
feeling that I want to get expressed out
there and make it into a video version
this has got to do it and he agreed and
he created an amazing product that we
were to put out on on YouTube and on our
websites so work with the best find
people who you look at their stuff and
it touches you because if it touches you
makes you feel something then it's
likely going to touch your audience with
the message that you're trying to get
out there number three plant seeds you
shouldn't have to do too much marketing
with the viral video because it's
supposed to be viral right it's supposed
to get out there people are supposed to
talk about it for you without having
advertised I got the over half a million
views on my video without spending money
on advertising just from people talking
about it but I still planted seeds at
the beginning so what I did was when the
video first came out I wrote to my
newsletter and i put on my social media
networks and i put on my website and my
two days also has a following so he put
it on his networks and we got a quick
initial surge of people coming to the
site not hundreds of thousands you know
maybe 10,000 I forget what it was on
that first day or maybe a few thousand
it wasn't that
but basically you're planting seeds so
that you have a lot of people watching
at the start and they can help spread
that message for you so it helps it
helps the video go viral much more
quickly so you don't need a plan this
huge massive campaign around it but you
want to have you want to have people who
are willing to watch it and share the
part of your network part of your
community so what I would do is you look
at who your customers are look at who
you already have on your social media
networks and share that video with them
and if you're co-creating with somebody
else have them help share just plant
some seeds so that's not starting from
absolutely nothing you have a little bit
of traction to start it off so remember
to get your viral video to work you want
to stand for something work with the
best and plant seeds believe for those
are watching you like the video you can
support me by clicking the link in the
description below give the video a
thumbs up leave a comment let me know
what you're thinking if you've created a
viral video I'd love to see it in the
comments below and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon